the police outside the front door were
the only sign of the royal patient
inside as Wokingham palace announced
that Prince Philip had been admitted to
hospital a statement said the duke of
edinburgh travelled from norfolk this
morning to the King Edward the seventh
Hospital in London for observation and
treatment in relation to a pre-existing
condition the admission is a
precautionary measure on the advice of
his Royal Highnesses doctor it is
inevitable that this would cause concern
when you're talking about a man who's 98
years old but I understand that Prince
Phillip wasn't brought here by ambulance
and was able to walk inside the hospital
by himself the reason that he was
brought from Norfolk down to London is
because this is a hospital that's used
to dealing with members the royal family
and the consultants who've been dealing
with that pre-existing condition are
based here last time the Duke was seen
out publicly with his family was in May
at lady Gabriella Windsors wedding he's
been spending most of his time in
Norfolk since he stepped back from
public duties in 2017 enjoying his
retirement he was still driving until
earlier this year when he was involved
in a car accident but despite signs that
he has been staying active including
enjoying his hobby of carriage driving
there has been speculation about his
health Prince Phillip has really
splendid health he said he hasn't had
the flu for years but he's always in
such good health but he is 98 and
suffered a few health scares has been
into the hospital a few times over the
last couple of years so obviously that
creates a lot of public concern as the
Duke was being taken to hospital the
Queen was seen arriving in Norfolk by
train to start her Christmas break at
Sandringham in what may be the biggest
hint that she's not overly concerned
about her husband the palace won't give
further updates on his condition medical
matters are always treated as private
but we do understand he's expected to
stay in hospital for a few days
rhiannon Mills Sky News at the King
Edward the seventh Hospital